[Music]
Courtney Cox is officially like the rest
of us spending her time on Instagram
trying out the friends filter you know
the one where you hold the camera to
your face and the internet works some
magic to tell you which character from
the hit sitcom you are well Courtney
shared the results on Instagram posting
all of her many and we mean many
attempts to finally land on her
character Monica yeah she got Rachel
Monica I want you to have the first
taste really
then she got Ross and Joey okay it's hot
with all this stuff fun I I better not
do any I don't know lunges
then there was Phoebe and she even got
Chandler I see I see you trying to freak
me out but eventually after taking a lot
of stabs at the filter she finally got
Monica
[Music]
if only there were a smaller one to
clean this one she captioned the
hilarious clip which was set to the
show's iconic theme song quote finally
got Monica thought I was gonna be ugly
naked guy for sure hashtag identity
crisis ugly naked guy is having
Thanksgiving dinner with ugly naked gal
okay is it just me or has Courtney
officially become the reigning queen of
Instagram I mean she nearly broke the
Internet over the weekend when she posed
for these pics with her friends co-stars
Jennifer Aniston and Lisa Kudrow Jen
posted the shots to her Instagram
alongside the caption hi from the girls
across the hall
oh and then there was this the 55 year
old recently shared at that video of her
slaying some serious choreography with
her 15 year old daughter Coco Coco's
really she's into musical theater so
yeah that's your passion
the clip got friends fans deep in their
throwback fields comparing her moves
with Coco to the routine she did with
her co-star David Schwimmer in friends
when et caught up with Courtney in 2018
she gushed over her time on the show
those were the days for sure I mean it's
I had such a name it was just the best
opportunity on the best show and I was
really lucky to be a part and become
friends and work with all of his
incredible people but what about all
those rumors that the cast might reunite
and bring a friends reboot to life when
he T caught up with Jennifer Aniston in
2019 she reveals that they're actually
working on something else together we
have the best time together and we're we
always aren't trying to think of
something to do you know we just have to
figure out what the right thing is but
we will please let it be true please let
it be true of course you can count on et
to be the first ones to let you know if
a friends reunion of any sort comes to
be so make sure to keep it locked right
here until next time I'm Hallie Stephens
bye for now
[Music]